[Music]
in setup news sweet yeah submitted by a
world peace for all
never got kiss yeah say I [ __ ] hit
your kiss I resorts are getting totally
fed up with barely famous influencers
requesting free rooms barely famous like
what they got like 200 followers I would
understand like for those hotels or
something like that they had like 3000
followers and like can I get a free room
it's like come on man might give them
something 3,000 yeah like you get 3000
followers you were not they're talking
about 2,000 fathers oh okay I was just
to put it in perspective like I have
like what like four and a thousand and
even then I don't ask like I don't feel
like maybe there I'm never I use my
credit card points yeah I don't feel
like I'm not there yet
like I need like a million I don't want
to work like even if it's not that much
work to post a picture
oh that's rain the brain goes oh no yeah
it's so weird asking for free stuff it's
like just paper I also kind of just know
who the [ __ ] you are [ __ ] yeah you know
like 3000 like you could get 3,000
followers or 2,000 just with your
friends alone yeah a little bit of extra
I've even done wha where they hit me up
about stuff and I like will pay you and
I'm just like dude I just like your [ __ ]
like just you giving it I don't work now
do you I don't want to let me just have
it yeah I say just give it to me and
then I will I'll promote if I want don't
pay me there's also a guy [ __ ] playing
hard to get and I'm kind of hurt wait
what so you know spar bar boxing oh yeah
yeah putting him on blast so they told
me that they're gonna send me this thing
that I was gonna get anyways oh hell
yeah send it to me I gave him my address
and I'm still waiting on it and now I'm
like you gonna make me buy it aren't you
I'm gonna buy it
imma buy it I'm still I must know
promote it yeah how long have you been
like a good six months oh I've been like
two months already a long time I was too
excited because when you when you I was
like you're gonna get a spa bottles like
fog I don't have a garage but it's like
having one because you'll have it I'll
put it here at bar bars frightening we
need more equipment here oh yeah we do
in the office of you're filming oh you
know what just put it in the other
office there's more space there I'm glad
that started out if you get the big
banana bag it wouldn't make sense
because then you could rest it on the
pillow cuz that package we're filming
here okay
hi yeah thank you for studying this
article thank well this one was easy but
thank you I appreciate it I'm not real
nervous I was like what is a little bit
of followers I just had this
conversation with a couple of my friends
but it applies it okay it's so funny
that like people with actual like
millions of followers are like hundreds
of thousands of followers don't act as
big-headed as people with 5004 they do
they do like yo wait let me show out
money real quickly said I looked at
somebody's profile the other day he
likes 750 followers and his profile
picture was like entrepreneur you know
boy if you know you want to know what's
even funnier that's this like stack of
cash it's like 20s it's public seven
hundred bucks
it's like [ __ ] you don't got a bank
account you dumb [ __ ] no okay whatever I
don't know it's so not it's nominal it's
nothing it's nothing the flaws yeah yeah
yeah the one I think is funny too is
like you were saying to send in our
followers and then they're like talking
to it like they're going live and
they're talking to all their people and
I'm just like that's wild you ever
thought somebody's live and they got
you're the only other person and there
you're like Amy I just want to say
what's up
respect the hustle you know what if
they're trying to build up their
chapters I respect the hustle but I
thought this one sweeping I was going
around so someone said that they like
they're so nice and they feel so bad
that every time they go into someone's
live and it's they're the only person in
the life that they feel so bad that I
presume that they actually stay and
watch the whole thing
I feel like that's of [ __ ] you do should
I do but nothing you have to watch
[ __ ] so Ricky shut it like this
really quick video this one like
Instagram light just came out and I saw
it he goes I don't like he's like I know
a lot of people might not find this
opinion popular but you know all those
people out there who go Instagram live
and you have nobody following you it's
not for you you're not supposed to use
it when you saw that one person pop up
you should have been like I'm a loser
does everyone have Instagram live maybe
it is for everyone no but you're not
supposed to use it yeah it's not for
everybody even if you have ten and it's
ten of your best friends and like you
guys are you do it's that's like [ __ ]
phone
you know what do you call it like 3-way
calling each other [ __ ] but you know it
still feels weird same yeah but it's
like it's like fanservice
you know they want to have a
conversation they want to see you online
because they appreciate it so I know no
life for you guys more I went live a
couple of times when I was driving
do you not supposed to do that really
yes I was bored come on you look at the
road look at the road for like 30
minutes
really we get on the road look on the at
the road of the company I do bars I like
this oh you [ __ ] maybe I know I would
Instagram live when I Drive but I had
the phone mount and I just looked
forward and I just talked oh you're not
reading the any and no like i'll read it
like if it's at a stoplight and I look
over but when I saw I just look forward
again maybe I should start doing that
too no I don't think you should I don't
think it's safe yeah we're not trying to
promote that I only hit it twice than
the other time I did a little hot tub
and I couldn't hear anything so I turned
off but you're only talking to yourself
I know if I can hear myself I know what
do you need it here mono yeah you fed
himself that's honesty right there like
you can't fault this guy though that's
the hottest man right there yeah we get
some examples of what the hell happened
oh yeah I mean this is super vague
that's why I was like thank you I
appreciate it but this is really easy so
they're just saying that a lot of
representatives from like five star
resorts in the mouth mile dives melting
all these these I don't know
everybody's being mad on us today no
just mom I ain't even trying multiband
Moldovan mana be back but they're just
saying that like everyone and their
mamas are trying to get a free stay
there and there just ain't like that
they want to stay there for ten days
that only has day that's what like an
eight thousand dollar brand deal if
those two thousand followers are like
every single celebrity known to mankind
and they're like super you know on top
of the world I'll be like yes no but the
celebrities like why would you want to
promote - so you want to promote to
regular people right I would promote to
like kings and queens but it's a hundred
percent true though like sometimes when
you're on vacation you just want a
vacation
because if I'm going to like for example
we've been to Hawaii multiple times and
then like in the place that I don't want
to stay is Waikiki and I have been
approached by hotels - oh if you do a
video you show a tour of the place I'm
not there to [ __ ] war dude I'm gonna
get Airbnb away from Waikiki and then
I'll come see you guys later
I just don't want to do it it makes
sense though if you want to spare a few
bucks but I just don't we've been on
social media and getting like
sponsorships for like the last ten years
so we have a different mentality
I remember how [ __ ] excited I was to
get [ __ ] I'm like where the first time
were like well it wasn't as elaborate as
this but like you you do remember like
your trips that are like wow I get to do
this for a living like you know I didn't
you like work well like even recently
when we all went to Hawaii we got to
swim with sharks and all those things it
was comped right but then it just felt
cool like I'm doing something that I
really want to do and I'm just kidding
that's how it's been recently like with
the Croatia yeah it's good you want to
do that super happy and it's not like
I'm getting paper [ __ ] hate your
[ __ ] guts I get happy when I go to
restaurant they're like appetizers on me
yeah
[Laughter]
I think what any just you yeah but I'm
saying like that level of grandiose
that's the extent that I get you got
Puerto Rico I got Puerto Rican
restaurant like yo not over the full
meal just the appetizer
I don't even get I don't even get that I
get the waiter who sneaks us free drinks
employee discount on my tab that's what
I you can't even cut me the meal for
free he's like you man I got you free
drinks on me don't let them see you have
that bottle alright I don't even drink
yeah you got to drink it now he starts
at I'm with ya anybody who sees me at a
restaurant
just get me give me like something like
a free spring roll dude it'll make me
feel really good yeah y'all really I'm
here I got like I got like an offer like
we will send you five e cigs if you will
post that you are considering its
ministry hey that's so fun
we'll send you five nicotine patches if
you do this for us you know it's funny
when people don't do their research too
so I get emails of like female brand
yeah I'm like why why am I gonna promote
your brand like I don't understand back
I'm like I don't know what I'm gonna do
with your bra you know that [ __ ] bra
that you do like this I'm like you
aren't really take it to move he did do
one he got titties though no he got a
girl like a girl to do it yeah that's
smart I did get one recently for a baby
products I'm like baby my I'm like most
of my audience like are younger and I
got an email the other day and was like
for a vibrator and I was like mmm know
what kind of I don't save second um I
don't know but I was like sorry I don't
think my demographic really fits into
this but please send me what I can't
promote it but yo can I get a discount
so there's representative here she's
also saying that it's people with 600
Facebook friends saying hey I'm an
influencer oh my god that's pretty low
yeah it is kind of a catch-22 though
when you need it like you need you don't
have that much money and you need the
discount and you need the free things is
when you don't really have the following
and then when you have the following and
when you can afford and you don't eat it
now like now they're giving it to you
for free oh that's true the perspective
that's very true yeah in the very
beginning I was so happy to get like
free clothes free everything and I just
like have a lot to pay for this [ __ ] I'm
saving money yeah and now I'm like yeah
well even now I can't afford the [ __ ]
that they're sending me on Wow nice yeah
like no but I'm saying like I had the
following but I can't afford it either
what I mean you went through the Paris
on and on on your own dime in Morocco on
her own dime oh that [ __ ] people think
we're balling - [ __ ] no we're not how'd
you afford those ballin ass earrings
that look like symbols the Walmart guys
this is the from Walmart well it looks
bottoms it's your fault you're tricking
me I think you're balling I'm like
[ __ ] those symbolizes you stop making
fun of her she got mini gongs
[Music]